i found this report hard to read
and it is a day of shame for the labour
party
we have failed jewish people
our members our supporters
and the british public and so
on behalf of the labour party i
am truly sorry for all the pain
and grief that has been caused
to jewish people our jewish members
our long-standing jewish affiliate jlm
to the people driven out of our party
the jewish members driven out of
parliament
including louise ellman and luciana
berger
and to the members of the labour party
staff
who spoke out i want
to say this i know
how hard these last few years have been
for you
how painful today will be
and how hard you had to fight to have
your voices heard
so let me be clear i hear you
and i can promise you this i will act
never again will labor let you down
never again will we fail to tackle
anti-semitism
and never again will we lose your trust
the labour party eye lead accepts this
report
in full and without qualification
we will implement all recommendations
and we will implement them
in full that process
starts today i've already instructed my
staff to start work with the commission
to implement the recommendations at the
earliest possible opportunity we will
provide the commission with our action
plan
to achieve all of this within six weeks
we will establish an independent
complaints process
and it will be in place as soon as
possible in the new year
we will ensure that neither the leader
the deputy leader
or our offices will have any involvement
in the outcome of complaints
initiated under the labour party
processes
and we are already addressing the
backlog of anti-semitism cases
in fact there have been more cases
completed in the last six months
than in the whole of 2019
but we will go much further and we must
go further
because as the report makes clear this
cannot be solved just by changing the
parties processes
and structures we also need
a culture change in the labour party
it must become once again
an open and welcoming place for people
from all backgrounds
and all communities under my leadership
zero tolerance of anti-semitism will
mean precisely that
if you're anti-semitic you should be
nowhere near this party
and we'll make sure you're not and if
after all the pain all the grief
and all the evidence in this report
there are still those who think there's
no problem with anti-semitism in the
labour party that it's all exaggerated
or a faction attack then frankly you are
part of the problem too
and you should be nowhere near the
labour party either
this report is painful to read
but i urge everyone to do so
because this must be a line in the sand
there could be no more missed
opportunities
no more denials or excuses
under my leadership labor will act
decisively
against anti-semitism in all its forms
we will repair the breach i know it will
take time
and hard work but when i stood for
leader of this party
i was clear that my first priority would
be to root out anti-semitism
and rebuild trust that started in april
we've made progress and it will
intensify today
but i will only consider a success when
those members who left our party
because of anti-semitism feel safe to
return
and when we no longer hear the words
labor and anti-semitism
in the same sentence thank you